schönen guten Morgen dass das Bild live
an diesem Donnerstag und gleich in der
breaking news ein Munitionslager der
Polizei steht in Flammen hier in der
Hauptstadt in Berlin im Grunewald da
sehen sie die Rauchschwaden dort über
dem Grunewald im Süden Berlins da knallt
seit den frühen Morgenstunden kräftig
seit kurz vor 4 Uhr immer wieder
Detonation Explosion damit sind die
Berliner dort im Süden der Stadt heute
aufgewacht sie sehen dass diesen
Großeinsatz der Feuerwehr dort gerade
die Bilder von unseren Reportern
geschickt mehr als 100 Feuerwehrleute
dort die den Brand im Grunewald
bekämpfen ein Munitionslager und das
sind massive Detonation schauen Sie hier
das sind Handyvideos geschickt von
Anwohnern dort das Munitionslager
abgesperrt dort im Wald durch diesen
Zaun und der hinter krachtest und knallt
es gewaltig nein das ist nicht das
Feuerwerk der Rolling Stones am Abend
wenn sie ganz kurz rein das sind massive
Explosionen dort im Süden der Hauptstadt
das ist ein ganz beliebtes Ausflugsziel
dort der südliche Grunewald jetzt um
diese Zeit da gehen die Berliner dort
mit ihren Hunden aus da machen sich die
ersten auf den Rädern unterwegs an der
Havel und zum Wannsee dort im Grunewald
und dort eben jetzt dieser Großbrand
noch unklar warum der ausgebrochen ist
wir haben gerade unsere Reporter mit der
Feuerwehr dort sprechen können was eine
mögliche Brandursache sein könnte
die Berliner Feuerwehr wurde heute um 3
Uhr an den Kronprinzessin Weg in
Nikolassee gerufen und dortigen
Sprengplatz Grunewald kam es zu mehreren
großen Explosionen und kommt immer noch
zu Explosionen
darüber hinaus kam es zu einem Brand der
sich sehr zügig auch aufgrund der
trockenen Vegetation auf den umliegenden
Waldbereich ausbreitete die erst
eintreffenden Kräfte konnten die Lage
schnell bestätigen und zügig groß nach
alarmieren zogen sich dann aber zurück
auch aufgrund der massiven
Explosionsgefahr des sprengplatzes da
dort immer noch viele Kampfmittel Lagern
also ein Munitionslager in der
Hauptstadt hier in Berlin ein
Munitionslager der Polizei steht in
Flammen seit den frühen Morgenstunden
seit etwa 4 Uhr das jetzt in diesen
morgendlichen Stunden die Rauchschwaden
dort im Süden Berlins über dem Grunewald
und das ganze hat noch eine Geschichte
nicht nur diese massiven Explosionen und
die dort nein im Süden Berlins ist
gerade auf den Straßen alles gesperrt
die awus die Autobahn wegen dieser
massiven Detonation die führt direkt
dort hinter dem Zaun lang die Autobahn
auf der anderen Seite und die ist
aktuell gesperrt im Berufsverkehr
bedeutet das eine Menge Ärger umsteigen
auf die S-Bahn ist mir die Berliner
aktuell nicht auch die S-Bahn dort im
Süden die Feld teilweise aus also das
beschäftigt im Moment die Hauptstadt
dieser massive Brand dort im Süden
Berlins in einem Polizei Munitionslager
Schlagerstar Annemarie Eilfeld und ein
Fan ein selfie ein scheinbar
alltäglicher Moment für die Sängerin
doch jetzt lässt dieser Schnappschuss
ihr das Blut in den Adern gefrieren es
ist ein Foto mit Eileens mutmaßlichem
Mörder Jan P der 29-Jährige liebt
Schalke und Schlagermusik wie die von
Annemarie Eilfeld im Mai 2018 kommt er
extra zu einer Premiere von Alfeld nach
Berlin und er schafft es die Musikerin
zu treffen unfassbar zu diesem Zeitpunkt
steht Jan P unter behördlicher
Beobachtung mit 14 Jahren versucht er
ein Mädchen zu vergewaltigen Jan P muss
zehn Jahre in die Psychoklinik mit
anschließender behördenaufsicht als
Rückfall gefährdeter
Sexualstraftäter nach seinem
Klinikaufenthalt zieht Jan P in die
hessische Gemeinde Walter Solms
dort soll er gelebt haben wie ein
Student wird gesagt heißt er hatte ein
eigenes Zimmer aber ohne eigenes Bad und
eigene Küche auch der Bürgermeister der
Gemeinde Walter Solms ist schockiert von
dem grausamen Verbrechen mutmaßlich
begangen von Jan P ich habe Enkelkinder
die eine ist auch fast in dem Alter und
ich denke unser Mitgefühl muss jetzt
zunächst einmal bei den Eltern den
Angehörigen
sein von meinen Mitarbeiterinnen weiß
ich dass bei ja ganz normalen
Behördengängen wie Beantragung
Personalausweis absolut freundlich
aufgetreten ist und mir selbst sind auch
keine negativen Dinge bekannt geworden
unauffällig nach Bildinformationen
genauso unauffällig wie seine
Führungsaufsicht Jan P hatte hier wohl
sehr selten Besuch worüber man sich im
Nachhinein wundert weil eigentlich hätte
er ja regelmäßig von Leuten aus der
Klinik beziehungsweise der Behörden
aufgesucht werden sollen wegen der
Kontrollen im Januar dieses Jahres endet
Jan PES Überwachung sechs Monate später
soll er Eileen im Internet geködert nach
Hessen verschleppt und ermordet haben
Staatsversagen
gewaltpräventionstrainer Carsten Stahl
ist überzeugt der Tod des jungen
Mädchens hätte verhindert werden können
die Gesellschaft und Menschen müssen wir
ihn geschützt werden aber wir schaffen
uns unsere Täter indem wir nicht
eingreifen wenn wir es könnten und das
nennt man Prävention bevor Menschen zu
Opfern und Tätern werden und da wird
versagt meine Tochter ist 11 Jahre
alt wie wollt ihr mein Kind schützen
muss ich es selbst schützen zehn Jahre
psycho-klinik und fünf Jahre staatliche
Überwachung keine Einsicht keine Reue
keine Kontrolle ungehindert konnte Jan P
Frauen stalken und womöglich nun Eileen
sogar töten
und mit Annemarie Eilfeld sind wir jetzt
verbunden mit der der mutmaßlichen
Mörder von Aline als selfie gemacht hat
wir haben es vorhin gesehen guten Abend
Frau Alfeld guten Abend mir Gänsehaut
gerade am ganzen Körper ja das glaube
ich das war vor fünf fünf Jahren als
dieses selfie entstanden können Sie sich
erinnern wie der Mann damals auf sie
wirkte
ja bei mir ist das halt immer so ich bin
normalerweise immer sehr gerne auch mit
Fans zusammen und man kennt sich ja nun
auch mittlerweile auf vielen
Veranstaltungen sieht man immer mal
wieder die gleichen Gesichter bei ihm
war es so dass mir der vorher noch nicht
aufgefallen ist den habe ich da das
erste Mal kennengelernt
nichtsdestotrotz immer so ein bisschen
ins Gespräch gekommen also er ist jetzt
relativ freundlich rübergekommen nur die
Fragen die haben mir dann gestellt hat
sind irgendwann halt immer unangenehmer
und immer spezieller geworden und das
fand ich in dem Moment komisch und das
ist auch der Grund warum ich mich extrem
gut daran erinnern kann ich weiß noch an
welchem Tag das war ich weiß noch was
ich davor gemacht habe ich weiß was ich
danach gemacht habe und ich kann mich
explizit an ihn als Person erinnern das
ist Wahnsinn das ist wirklich sehr
ungewöhnlich immerhin das ist fünf Jahre
her sie haben vorhin gesagt jetzt
bekommen Sie im Nachhinein eine
Gänsehaut wie fühlten sie sich damals in
dem Moment
wahnsinnig unangenehm das weiß ich halt
noch dass ich an dem Tag in Berlin
mehrere Termine hatte und bin dann
abends so der Premiere gegangen habe das
auch wie man so normalerweise macht mit
den Fans geteilt hey heute abend bin ich
am Potsdamer Platz und ich schaue mir
die Premiere von so und so an und das
wird ein toller Abend ich freue mich und
da ist es dann halt so dass wenn manche
das mitbekommen sie eben die Gelegenheit
nutzen man selfie zu machen
vorbeizukommen so ein bisschen da am
roten Teppich zu stehen so ein bisschen
unterstützlich Gewitter mitzunehmen das
ist völlig normal und so war es eben
auch bei ihm er war dann da ich wusste
nicht dass der von so weit hergekommen
ist also normalerweise sind das immer so
Berliner oder Brandenburger die dann da
warten am Potsdamer Platz und bei ihm
war es dann eben so dass er explizit
danach fragte wo denn mein Freund ist
warum der nicht mit dabei ist ob ich
alleine gekommen bin ob warum er mich
alleine lässt und ob wir überhaupt noch
zusammen sind
was mir halt total unangenehm war weil
ich das normalerweise nicht kenne von
von meinen Zuschauern und von meinem
Publikum Fans man fragt zwar hey Wo ist
ein Tim aber es war noch nie so dass
einer so penetrant immer wieder
nachgefragt hat und das war mir dann
halt schon ein bisschen unangenehm ich
habe dann auch das Foto gemacht selber
man sieht es glaube ich auch auf dem
selfie dass ich die Kamera halte weil er
so gezittert hat und dann bin ich dann
auch schnell nach drin verschwunden
nachdem das gemacht war
jetzt dieser schreckliche Verdacht und
das muss man noch mal betonen der
mutmaßliche Mörder noch ist der nicht
verurteilt aber heute Nachmittag vor gut
einer Stunde haben sie festgestellt dass
er ihnen auch auf Instagram noch folgt
wie fühlen sie sich damit jetzt
ja gut man kann es ja immer nicht
beeinflussen wer einem folgt und was
derjenige diejenige für eine
Vergangenheit hat man kann ja die Leute
auch immer unmöglich reingucken
grundsätzlich ist es schon ja ein Gefühl
was jetzt nicht gerade angenehm ist
zumal er auch einigen von meinen
Freunden folgt was ich gesehen habe aus
Berlin was ich halt ja irgendwie schon
ein bisschen suspekt finde aber was was
soll ich was soll ich sagen also
mir gegenüber hat er sich jetzt in
Anführungszeichen freundlich Verhaltens
war sehr penetrant aber zum Glück ist
nichts weiter passiert aber letztendlich
macht man sich ja schon seine Gedanken
zumal ich auch gerade in der Zeit 2017
zum Beispiel ein Stalker hatte der mich
hat dann bis nach bis dazu getrieben hat
dass ich dann aus Berlin weggezogen bin
ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie mit uns so
offen gesprochen haben
danke
er kann Löffel verbiegen mit der Kraft
seiner Gedanken angeblich so ist der
weltberühmt geworden sie kennen alle Uri
Geller ja der tv-magier Mensch der ist
inzwischen ein bisschen älter geworden
75 Jahre alt der Mann aus Israel und
jetzt ganz mit was anderem im Geschäft
er droht nämlich Putin und das meinte
richtig ernst der Uri Geller ja der
droht nämlich Putin ich werde deine
Atomraketen umlenken und zwar hier
wieder mit der Kraft meiner Gedanken Uri
Geller der Magier der knöpft sich Putin
vor mit diesem Video zum Beispiel
ich habe eine Warnung für Sie Putin ich
fordere Sie auf meine Warnung zu lesen
Sie alle denn ich meine es ernst sehr
ja er spricht also eine ernste Warnung
aus der Uriella und hat gleichzeitig ein
offene Brief noch nachgelegt an Vladimir
auch mal rein und da sagte das nämlich
auch ganz genau ich spreche eine ernste
Warnung an sie aus ich werde jedes
allerkleinste Molekül der Kraft meiner
Gedanken einsetzen um sie daran zu
hindern Atomraketen einzusetzen und das
meinte total ernst ja und er schließt
diesen Brief mit diesen Worten hier ihre
kontroll-computer also ihre Herr Putin
ihre kontrollcomputer die werden crashen
ihren Navigationssysteme die werden
ausfallen ihrer Raketen werden Versagen
ich habe sie gewarnt ruhiger
super wenn er das könnte ja und wir
haben nicht schlecht gestaunt vor
wenigen Stunden was Putins Propaganda TV
gerade mit unseren wildreportern macht
hier schauen Sie mal da knöpft sich der
Chef propagandis von Putin Pop-Off heißt
der Mann unseren Kriegsreporter Björn
Stritzel vor der seit Monaten so
praktisch so sachlich aus der Ukraine
Putins Chef Propagandist der redet über
Björn dort die ganze Zeit dieser
putinpropagandist in seiner russen-show
60 Minuten bezeichnet auch unseren Björn
als Nazi immer wieder zeigt dieser Jeff
gehen die Popo auf unseren Reporter da
im Einsatz vor den Deutschen
Panzerhaubitzen und verleumdet ihn vor
einem millionenpublik dafür ist diese
frontreportage von Björn Stritzel der
berichtet er aus der Ostukraine vom
Einsatz der deutschen Panzerhaubitzen
2000 die mittlerweile im Alltagseinsatz
dort sind an der Front in der Ukraine
die deutschen Nazi Faschisten Spitzen so
heißt das dann in Putin TV und Björn
wird immer immer wieder ebenfalls als
Nazi bezeichnet bildchef Johannes Boje
bei uns im Studio also unser
Bildreporter unser Björn dort verleumdet
im Russen TV im Putin TV was bedeutet
das für Björn was bedeutet das aber für
Bild i guten Morgen erstmal also es ist
natürlich ein sagenhafter Angriff auf
die Pressefreiheit da muss man sagen das
sind wir von der folterdiktatur in
Moskau mittlerweile natürlich gewöhnt
trotzdem wichtig dass auch noch mal
ausdrücklich zu sagen im Westen sind wir
nicht so hier lassen wir Journalisten
unsere Arbeit machen das haben die
Russen nicht mehr drauf das wollen sie
nicht andererseits natürlich auch ein
sagenhaftes Lob für Björn für seine
fantastische Arbeit er ist der erste und
der einzige der diese Panzerhaubitzen
2000 die Deutschland jetzt ja endlich
geschickt hat wirklich im Einsatz auch
begleiten konnte und so wie sich die
Russen darüber aufregen ist das
eigentlich ein großes Lob für unsere
Arbeit das heißt du siehst so ein
Angriff eher eigentlich als Bestätigung
vielleicht gar sogar als Motivation dass
wir unsere Arbeit als Journalistinnen
und Journalisten genauso fortführen ganz
klar Patricia es ist ja so dass
Journalismus versucht immer neutral zu
sein und versucht eigentlich keine
Gegnerschaft zu dem aufzubauen über das
wir berichten aber hier ist die Lage
ebenso klar die Russen wollen ja gar
kein Journalismus die Russen haben die
Journalismus abgeschafft es ist nur noch
Propaganda und dass wir dann eben
kritisiert werden zeigt dann ja doch
schon dass wir die Gegner sind und in
dem Fall in diesem einen Fall natürlich
dann auch dass wir einen guten Job
machen weil es hier keine Gegnerschaft
ist über Inhalte ist das richtig ist das
richtig sondern ist eine Gegnerschaft
Journalismus vs Propaganda und je mehr
die Russen auf uns auf Bild einprügeln
und das tun sie ja schon seit Monaten
mit Björn das ist jetzt einfach ein
neuer Höhepunkt
umso mehr versichert es mir eigentlich
dass wir einen guten Job machen gestern
habe ich in Report bekommen der gerade
in Russland rumgereicht wird
von einer Organisation die dort
Medienarbeit im Westen auswertet und da
stand absatzweise was Bild alles macht
ja also aus der russischen Sicht aus der
aus der Sicht der Folter Diktatur wie
schlimm das ist dass wir so gute
Reporter haben dass wir in der Ukraine
vor Ort sind dass wir in
russischsprachiges Programm auszahlen ja
und das ist natürlich für mich liest
sich das wie ein Lob also vielen Dank an
die Duma an die Propagandisten da wir
haben das gehört wir nehmen das zur
Kenntnis großes Lob für Björn Stritzel
und alle unsere Reporterinnen und
Reporter in der Ukraine weil Bild eben
auch auf Russisch sendet das hast du
gerade noch mal gesagt Johannes ganz
wichtig auch deswegen offenbar Putin TV
und Putins Chef propagandis kräftig
genervt von uns von unseren Reportern
von unserer Berichterstattung dort aus
der Ukraine danke Johannes wir müssen
aber noch einmal auch über Gas Gerd
sprechen denn auch der hat viele genervt
wieder weil er sich groß zu Wort
gemeldet hat am gestrigen Tag über den
Stern in einem da waren besser Wisser
Interview dort mit der Überschrift warum
soll ich mich eigentlich entschuldigen
schauen wir mal rein in dieses Interview
der fallenden paar gute
putinenpropaganda-sätze kann man sagen
schon der Titel allein sehen sie ja hier
warum soll ich mich entschuldigen aber
dann dann hat er auch noch folgende Idee
er will Nord Stream 2 in Betrieb nehmen
die einfachste Lösung wäre die Pipeline
nothings 2 so sagte in Betrieb zu nehmen
mit beiden nordstream Pipelines gäbe es
kein Versorgungsproblem für die deutsche
Industrie könnte das ein oder andere
eigene geschäftliche Interesse bei der
Aussage Rolle gespielt haben bei Gas
Gerd jedenfalls hat sich der ukrainische
Staatspräsident selensky auch zum
gasgärt geäußert jetzt zumindest
indirekt seinen Namen mag er nicht in
den Mund nehmen aber das die Aussage von
Vladimir Vladimir silenski dem
ukrainischen Staatspräsidenten zu diesen
Zitaten von Gas gibt
das Verhalten von Gerhard Schröder ist
einfach ekelhaft ekelhaft wenn ehemalige
Führer großer Staaten mit europäischen
Werten für Russland arbeiten denn
Russland ist im Krieg mit genau diesen
Werten
ja das also genau diese Werte die er
dort beschreibt und Schröder der
gleichzeitig darüber spricht dass
Russland verhandlungsbereit sei also er
den ja dir das Handlungsspektrum so
erweitert dass es eigentlich ja nur
Johannesburg unser Chefredakteur noch
bei uns hier im Studio an uns liegt
dieses verhandlungsgebot dann auch mal
aufzunehmen und einzugehen wie findest
du das wie findest du das dass ein
Altkanzler solche Worte die auch in der
Ukraine für so ein Ekel sorgen für so
ein Unverständnis sorgen äußert Patricia
ist es würde los es ist wirklich
beschämend und wir haben hier ein
ehemaligen deutschen Bundeskanzler bei
dem wir uns mittlerweile dieselben
Fragen stellen müssen wie bei einem
25-jährigen Nazi wie bei einer
30-jährigen linksextremistin bis wohin
gilt die Meinungsfreiheit wie muss man
die Äußerung bewerten ja das ist etwas
was man aushalten muss ich meine wir
kennen das alle von der Meinungsvielfalt
in der Demokratie aber das ein
ehemaliger deutschen Bundeskanzler sich
zu sowas hinreißen lässt
ist einfach unterirdisch es ist wirklich
beschämend und ich bin nur froh darüber
dass Gerhard Schröder eigentlich
weitgehend auch aus dem Diskurs
herausgedrängt wurde alle wissen auch
dass Gerhard Schröder sehr sehr viel
trinkt ich rede regelmäßig mit Menschen
die in sehr gut kennen die beschreiben
das immer wieder viele Weinlieferungen
der Wein wird früh am Tag aufgemacht so
wird es mir berichtet und ich denke das
ordnet eigentlich ganz gut ein wie man
das ernstzunehmen hat nämlich gar nicht
ich finde auch die Medien haben hier
eine Verantwortung die Frage ist gibt
man Gerhard Schröder noch eine Plattform
ja oder nein er ist nichts anderes als
ein gaslobbyist als ein Lobby ist so ein
Putin der hier die Regierungsarbeit der
russischen Kriegsverbrecher übernimmt
und macht muss man halt dann auch
genauso bewerten und vielleicht auch
nicht weiters ernst nehmen
vielen herzlichen Dank für diese
Einordnung danke auch für deinen Besuch
hier im Studio danke China eskaliert hat
jetzt vor wenigen Minuten offiziell
bestätigt
riesiges Militärmanöver hat begonnen
trainieren für einen Krieg um taiwa und
dieses Manöver das ist nichts anderes
als eine massive Kriegsdrohung china
will sich Taiwan einverleiben das alles
passiert wenige Stunden nachdem die
amerikanische Spitzenpolitikerin Nancy
Pelosi ein Taiwan zu Besuch war und
bestätigt hat dass die USA Taiwan voll
zur Seite stehen werden im Ernstfall und
jetzt jetzt droht Chinas Diktator Ski
die Welt in einen neuen Krieg dort zu
ziehen Bilder die tatsächlich auch hier
in Deutschland Angst zu machen und es
gibt wieder neue corona-regeln für
Deutschland das ist er der Herbst und
winterplan der Bundesregierung ja der
ist nicht einfacher geworden das sehen
Sie schon an dieser massiven Regelung
hier den man ganz versucht hat
vereinfacht darzustellen und der ist
trotzdem ganz schön in sich hat also das
soll er sein Herbst und winterplan man
hat hier wieder drüber geschrieben die
Winterreifen das hat sich Karl
Lauterbach ja so schön ausgedacht und
die Schneeketten also das was auf jeden
Fall kommt die Winterreifen und das was
im äußersten Notfall kommt die
Schneeketten und dann schauen wir hier
in die Regelungen mal rein die Maske die
spielt eine ganz große Rolle wieder im
Herbst und im Winter leider die FFP 2
Maske im fern und Flugverkehr soll
wieder Pflicht werden Ausnahme Personal
nur die medizinische Maske und dann in
Krankenhäusern auch da gibt es Ausnahmen
FFP 2 Maske und Test sollen Pflicht sein
aber dann nicht für die die frisch
geimpft sind oder frisch genesen sind
und dann gibt es weitere Regelungen für
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr auch dort
ffp2-maskenpflicht Personal aber nur die
medizinische Maske und in den Schulen
sieht es dann wiederum anders aus da
kommen nämlich nicht nur die Masken ins
Spiel sondern vor allen Dingen hier für
alle Schüler und Schülerinnen in
Deutschland die Tests wieder und das ist
das was wir hoffen was uns allen erspart
bleibt im Herbst und im Winter nämlich
im Grunde die aller corona-maßnahmen
wieder Abstandsgebot Hygienekonzepte
personenobergrenze Veranstaltung in
Innenräumen wieder nur noch mit einer
bestimmten Personenanzahl all das droht
schon wieder hier auf diesem neuen
corona-plan der Bundesregierung also man
guckt sich nicht besonders gerne an und
trotzdem muss man einmal drauf geschaut
haben die Bundesregierung plant massiv
mit maskenpflicht und auch wieder mit
weiteren corona-maßnahmen für Herbst und
für Winter doch wieder Atomkraft die
Mehrheit der Deutschen will genau das
inzwischen klar weil die Energie ja
gerade so knapp und zu teuer wird weil
die Preise explodieren explodieren doch
wieder Atomkraft der politische Druck
von ihm auch der wächst massiv auch von
ihm heute kommt Deutschland dieser
atomkraftwände wieder ein Schritt näher
es geht genau um dieses Atomkraftwerk
dieses Kernkraftwerk der Isar 2 sie
weiter voll dagegen Ricarda lang die
Grünen ko-chefin als der letzten drei
deutschen Kernkraftwerke endet dieses
Jahr
soll in Isa 2 kein Strom mehr produziert
werden aber jetzt machen die beiden
Druck hier Friedrich Merz rechts im Bild
CDU-Chef und Markus Söder CSU-Chef beide
besuchen das hier Isa 2 in wenigen
Stunden und was das heißt ist doch
völlig klar Druck auf die Regierung die
Botschaft wir wollen noch Atomkraft wie
die Mehrheit der Deutschen jetzt jetzt
soll die Regierung Handeln der Kanzler
der schwankt noch schließt die
atomkraftwände längst nicht mehr aus das
ist das was er vor 24 Stunden dazu
gesagt hat
was die Energieversorgung in Deutschland
betrifft sind die drei letzten
Atomkraftwerke wie jeder weiß
ausschließlich relevant für die
Stromproduktion und nur für einen
kleinen Teil davon aber trotzdem kann
das Sinn machen
das kann Sinn machen sagt also der
Kanzler und die Außenministerin die
grüne Annalena baerbock die sagt das
dazu vor wenigen Stunden sie schließt
nämlich genau das kategorisch aus als
Mitglied der Grünen sind
Laufzeitverlängerung für mich keine
Option sagt sie also da ist Softwaren
die AK Wände heute kommt Deutschland
möglicherweise in Schritt näher durch
diesen politischen Druck den die
Opposition heute aufbaut Friedrich Merz
Markus Söder zu Besuch bei Isa 2 und wir
schauen uns die wesentlichen Fakten zur
Atomkraft hier in Deutschland noch mal
an das ist die aktuelle Karte der
Kernkraft in Deutschland
33 Atomkraftwerke noch im Moment am Netz
dieser 2 taucht hier zweimal auf weil es
zwei Blöcke gibt von Isa 2 Emsland und
Neckarwestheim 2 das sind die
Atomkraftwerke die bis Ende dieses
Jahres also noch Kernkraft noch Strom
liefern ja und wir schauen uns dieses
Isa 2 Atomkraftwerk noch mal ein
bisschen genauer an das Atomkraftwerk
was am leichtesten ein bisschen
zumindest ein paar Monate länger laufen
könnte ist da im Landkreis Landshut seit
2011 ist der eine Block dort von Isa
abgeschaltet und mittlerweile seit März
2011 eben nur noch dieser Block 2 im
Betrieb und jetzt läuft voll die
Diskussion an deswegen Markus Söder
Friedrich Merz heute zu Besuch dass man
das eben wenigstens ein paar Monate
länger laufen lassen kann
[Musik]